get engaged left and right contact right
contact right back of our vehicle just
got hit 20 trillion Marines up there
that got hit pretty catastrophic
my name is Chris Merkel I'm a veteran
the United States Marine Corps you know
full-time student trying to reinvent
myself in transition back into a normal
civilian life joined right out of high
school when I was a seventeen my role in
the Marine Corps was just a grunt
infantryman so nothing fancy just the
down-and-dirty of what war comes down to
you experience something that's horrific
that your body doesn't know how to
comprehend and when you don't address it
it just manifests in this horrible thing
and you end up locked in a room hating
the world thinking everybody's coming
after you and I didn't want to be that
person talk therapy after talk to air
pee it wasn't working and I was like now
what what am I gonna do
virtuality was a godsend you can begin
to narrate the experience that he went
through all right so it's a really dark
it's early morning all right there you
go start taking some small arms fire
machine-gun fire I can do a big
explosion up ahead just a really surreal
scene to see I think it's hard for
people to imagine the enormity of the
challenges that people face when they
come back for more and adjust the
civilian life we can activate emotions
in a very deep way in VR helping a
patient go back and confront and process
very difficult emotional memories
advanced processing power faster
computers are essential for delivering
good VR with the technology getting
better computers have gotten faster and
you know things like some of the latest
Intel processors through mind-blowing
they're like rockets and so that's why
we can deliver VR that can make a
difference in people's lives you know we
ask so much of our service members and
we can't forget them when they come back
they deserve our best efforts and the
best technology available to help them
get back on the right track for the rest
of their life so I'm setting a new path
myself I want to be a clinical
psychologist I finished my undergrad
literally two weeks ago I jumped ahead
to master's in a doctoral program
yesterday
I have five years ahead of me and then a
whole lifetime ahead of that
we help as many people as I can and go
to school and help others VR is a
transformative technology that's going
to change everything about how we learn
how we heal how we experience places
that we could never go to the cool thing
is that these are really consumer
products everyone will have one in their
home and the advanced level of
processing that we're getting allows
everyone to be able to buy a computer
that'll run a state-of-the-art VR
headset and you'll be able to consume
media in dramatically new ways there's
so much value beyond just entertainment
to use it the power of this technology
to help people that is really exciting
for me
[Music]
you